a terra Mi hanno chiesto di parlare a un
pubblico riunito ad ascoltarmi ma
soprattutto a guardarmi parlare Ho
provato una serie di sensazioni che
riconosco come sintomi reazioni del mio
corpo alla paura
visto che la sensazione è un sentire
passivo qualcosa che subisco che mi
arriva ed è fulmineo e anche molto
onesto non ho potuto evitare di sentire
la testa pesante il battito cardiaco
accelerato le gambe rigide e i piedi
bollenti quindi
analizzando i miei sintomi corporei a
questa notizia Mi sono accorta che erano
tutti stati provocati da una semplice
immagine
il calore delle luci che mi illuminano e
mi rendono visibile a tante persone
silenziose sedute protette dal buio
della sala tutti i loro sguardi su di me
e a lungo appiccicati alla mia figura
Allora nella mia esperienza ultra
ventennale di conduzione di laboratorio
di pratiche corporee per gruppi di
cittadini dai tre ai 99 anni fuori e
dentro la scuola ho scoperto moltissimo
della pratica del guardare e dell'essere
guardati
ogni giorno veniamo colpiti da centinaia
di sguardi e a nostra volta colpiamo con
lo sguardo gli sguardi
sono corpo e guardare è toccare a
distanza
gli sguardi sono armi potentissime e
producono ultimo motivi anche quando non
sono lanciati a tale scopo
per riuscire a superare l'impatto
emotivo dell'essere Colpita da tutti i
vostri sguardi e comunque dall'essere
colpito da chi guarda per riuscire a
mantenermi in apertura disponibile a
comunicare con serenità ho ideato una
pratica di sguardo che ho chiamato lo
sguardo dell'Aquila ora per permettermi
di continuare questo mio intervento vi
chiedo di sperimentarlo con me
visto che siete tutte e tutti seduti
Non c'è bisogno visto che lo sguardo
arriva lontano riusciamo a vedere anche
il sole e la luna non c'è bisogno di
spostarsi quindi è qualcosa che potete
fare esattamente dove siete
allora
intanto ve lo spiego siete pronti siete
pronte vi chiedo di accorgervi che la
nostra visione è una visione che io
chiamo a cono con la base del cono
appoggiata ai nostri occhi e il nostro
sguardo che focalizza il vertice un
punto in cui decidiamo di mettere tutto
il nostro interesse e diventa L'unico
obiettivo del nostro guardare questo è
lo sguardo a cono non mi interessa
osservare nulla al di fuori di quanto
c'è o fuori intorno a questa visione ora
se io voglio vedere qualcos'altro
Infatti non faccio altro che muovere la
testa e rifocalizzare a cono un altro
obiettivo quindi passo da un obiettivo
all'altro continuamente escludendo tutto
quello che è intorno all'obiettivo
ora quello che vi chiedo di sperimentare
e di ribaltare la visione e farla
diventare lo sguardo dell'Aquila e il
ribaltare il cono significa mettere il
vertice dietro e il cono
è tutto intorno al vostro al vostro
volto e la visione cioè il gelato nel
cono è tutto ciò che abbiamo intorno
Quindi come dobbiamo fare Dobbiamo
comunque
cercare un punto dove focalizzare lo
sguardo che non sono io in questo
momento Quindi pronti allenamento Pronti
Via Guardate un punto dritto davanti a
voi
ognuno di voi si focalizza in quel punto
e però a un certo punto smette di
focalizzare e si concentra a vedere
aiutandosi anche con le mani tutto ciò
che c'è intorno quindi riesco a vedere
le mie mani a destra e sinistra Provate
a usare le mani
Io guardo dritto non muovo le pupille ma
ho le mani le vedo benissimo Poi vedo
l'alto e il basso questa visione
circolare Ovale che ho intorno me la
tengo tutto il tempo è una cosa molto
interessante è che questo sguardo mi
permette continuate ad allenarvi Eh non
Guardate me Guardate il punto mi
permette di osservare tutto quello che
ho intorno senza fissare e fissarmi su
nulla osservando con distacco ciò che
accade intorno a me e la cosa più
interessante è che dentro questa visione
Ci sono anch'io perché riesco a vedere
tratti del mio volto io vedo un po' il
mio naso e gli zigomi continuate a
fissare in questo modo aprire la visione
datevi il tempo di percepire la
differenza non ho bisogno di girare lo
sguardo per
vedere qualcos'altro che c'è intorno a
me perché tutto quello che è intorno
entra nella visione e tutti ci rendiamo
conto che siamo connessi grazie a questa
visione ora chiudete gli occhi
Riposatevi per un attimo
e quando li riaprirete riattivate lo
sguardo abituale Grazie davvero della
disponibilità per aver praticato con me
questo sguardo che però vi ha permesso
di mettervi nei miei panni cioè di
sperimentare con me questo strumento che
io uso per superare la paura di essere
guardata e mi fa sentire dentro ad una
visione molto ampia che non contiene
solo me ma mi mette in relazione con
tutte e tutti voi in uno stretto
collegamento è una pratica che io ho
chiamato empatia muscolare sentire
dentro quello che sente l'altra e
praticare quello che l'altra pratica Ora
però
vi chiedo di accorgervi del tipo di
sguardo che state mettendo in campo
fissando me
questo tipo di sguardo secondo voi è
adatto a farmi sentire a mio agio
a farmi superare le sensazioni di paura
di disagio che incontrerò durante il
tempo del choc come vi dicevo prima
guardare è toccare a distanza
gli sguardi sono armi potentissime e
producono urti e motivi quindi che tipo
di tocco volete per formare su di me
oggi Mi volete dare uno schiaffo
mi volete spingere o Mi volete dare un
tocco che
mi sostiene non mi fa cadere mi fa
sentire il sostegno di tutti voi Quindi
che tipo di sguardo vi chiedo di
sperimentare ora è un tipo di sguardo
che sempre nelle pratiche che propongo
chiamate lo sguardo sincero
[Musica]
questa pratica lo sguardo sincero perché
è stato chiamato sincero perché viene
dal Significato
etimologico della parola sincera cioè un
fiume di miele senza impurità senza cera
che ostacoli e la comunicazione quindi
un fiume denso e dorato tiepido in cui
tutte e tutti siamo immersi per riuscire
a fare questo devo riuscire a far uscire
questo tipo di sguardo dai miei occhi
ora vi chiedo di sperimentarlo su di me
ma visto che siete protette protetti dal
buio della sala vi dovrò costringere a
mettervi in gioco Cioè Chiedo agli
organizzatori di per questa pratica solo
per questa pratica di accendere le luci
di Sala così riesco a vedere i vostri
occhi
grazie grazie davvero ok Allora pronti
per per fermare lo sguardo sincero
Guardate me appoggiate il vostro sguardo
a me al mio corpo al mio volto e adesso
cercate di però di guardarmi mantenendo
l'attenzione all'interno a tutto quello
che accade dentro il vostro corpo le
sensazioni che state percependo
attenzione al tipo di postura che avete
non una postura chiusa non un braccio
così che giudica non la testa inclinata
e guardate la testa inclinata già molto
vuol dire ma una sguardo che apre Sento
già il fiume di miele che arriva che mi
sta in qualche modo già avvicinando a
voi E così siamo tutti tutti dentro
questo fiume
ora è questo sguardo non commenta e non
giudica mi sostiene mi incoraggia e vi
dà modo di comprendere le difficoltà
emotive che io sto provando
continuate a mantenere ancora questo
sguardo Grazie
Respirate osservate quello che vi accade
all'interno mentre Guardate me molto
bene
ora chiudete gli occhi riposateli per un
attimo e poi li potete riaprire
questo tipo di sguardo è sicuramente una
delle attività che sembra molto semplici
ma è una delle attività più
rivoluzionarie proposte per iniziare
effettivamente a modificare l'ambiente
corporeo delle aule scolastiche Durante
gli incontri dei laboratori che conduco
perché riesce a creare un ambiente in
pochi minuti come è capitato tra noi ha
condiviso dove diventare meno
competitivi e competitive me e più
collaborative meno guardinghe e più
fiduciose e a farci sentire parte di un
gruppo eterogeneo
Grazie davvero di aver praticato con me
questo sguardo e visto che vi siete
accorti che lo sguardo che scegliete di
attivare produce delle conseguenze
vi chiedo di mantenere questo tipo di
sguardo anche per tutti gli altri
relatori Grazie